- [Adam Lefkoe:] Is Bobby Portis underrated?
Corner three. Badge on the line.
- [Ronnie 2K:] It's how champions are made.
- Welcome to Underrated,
the only show that improves your favorite
professional athletes' video game ratings.
And today, a world champ, Bobby Portis.
It's time we get his 2K ratings way up.
When, when Jrue drives the lane
or Giannis kicks it out,
there is something about you
knocking down
a three that always feels like a back-breaker.
- Yeah.
- What is it
like to take the soul of another team?
- I mean, um,
just playing with great players makes you,
you know, play better as well.
Just being around those guys
made me change on and off the court.
But, like you said, when those guys
kick, kick the ball out to me and certainly
I'm open in the corner and somebody's
flying, I can fly by and look behind and see that you can make it.
- Yeah.
- I mean, those are the,
I mean, those type are what you live for.
-  Dap up the bench.
- Yeah. Dance a little bit.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. That's my thing.
- Well, that was the rating that I want to,
I want to fix today is I want it that
even if somebody is closing in on you,
it doesn't impact you.
- Nah.
- I got the guy here that can do it.
- Yes, sir.
- Let's bring him out. Heyo, Ronnie!
- What's up?
- Good to see you.
Lefkoe.
- Always a pleasure.
- Yes, sir.
- I need you to explain this to me.
If he's there and he's shooting
and there's a guy coming at him,
is there a badge
that means you're really great at this?
Cuz I think he's phenomenal at it.
- Yeah. Well, I mean, there's two things.
First of all, catch and release,
which I know he's really good at.
- Yeah.
- But the badge that we're talking about
is Dead Eye. Make sure
to hit the shots when the defense
is collapsing on someone.
If that badge is good, you can shoot it
right in the eye of your opponent.
- And so what, what—
is he gold in that right now?
Is he silver?
- I hate to break this to him.
He actually does not have a badge at all.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Not even a bronze, bro.
- Not even a bronze.
- Well, that's what this show is about, right?
I'm here.
- So you're telling me he can get one today?
- Perhaps.
He's going to have to show me.
- [Adam:] All right, Bobby. Here's how it works.
We got five spots.
Ten shots.
Got to hit seven out of 10.
- OK.
- As soon as you catch the ball,
they're throwing one of these monster
balls at you.
- OK.
- Don't even worry about it.
- All right.
- Because you're a Dead Eye.
- Yes, sir. Let's do it.
- You're getting a badge.
- Let's do it.
- He's getting a badge.
- Let's find out.
- Three, two, one, go.
Bang.
There it is.
We're 1-of-1.
2-of-2.
- Thought I wasn't going to make it, on rip.
- All right.
Now he's feeling it.
The confidence is in. Elbow shot.
Catch. Ball. Bang. Unfazed.
3-of-3. Fourth one.
A high one.
- Oh, no problem whatsoever.
- In his vision. No problem.
- No problem.
- Floater. How's your floater game?
- Ah, yep. You gotta, you gotta,
you gotta pump-fake the defender.
When he flying by get to your—
- How are you gonna pump-fake a big one?
- I dunno.
- I can't wait to see it.
¬- Ooh. All right.
4-of-5.
Second floater.
That went in.
Bobby Portis, 5-of-6.
Bang.
Do you see the anger in his face
right now?
- Yes.
- Ooh.
All right. You're on fire.
6-of-8.
Just 1-of-2, Bobby.
- I need 1-of-2?
- But what we're going to do
is we're adding an extra defender.
- Which one? Oh, my God.
- A full closeout.
So two shots.
You gotta hit one.
Bronze badge on the line.
How you feeling?
- Feeling great.
- He's feeling great.
- He thought this was gonna be easy.
00:04:19,676 --> 00:04:21,719
- [Adam:] Here it is.
- [Ronnie:] Oh.
- Oh. And so it all comes down to this.
He's holding his follow through.
- You know, there's a lot on the line now.
- [Adam:] How you feeling?
- [Ronnie:] I mean, this is his game.
He can prove it to me right here.
Big shot.
- It all comes down to this.
Corner three. Badge on the line.
Whenever you're ready.
- It's how champions are made.
- Oh! The kid is clutch.
And a little Griddy for the kids at home.
- Unbelievable.
- Do you feel comfortable right now
- Great question.
Great question. Great question.
- saying let's give this man the bronze
badge, cuz I know you got pull.
- Yeah.
Well, I will say I was surprised
he didn't have a bronze badge to begin with.
So, like, it's one of those things.
He came out and he showed out.
I got to talk to the team. Going to have to see what happens.
- I appreciate the honesty, man.
- Was he underrated?
So I can put on the bottom of the screen
right now,
he ended up getting the bronze badge.
- Yes.
- OK. OK.
Do you feel good about that?
- Absolutely, man.
I appreciate that, baby.
- Bobby Portis. My man.
We're gonna get him a gold badge.
All right.
So we need to see since Bobby,
since Bobby did it.
And these balls, they, you know,
they look like a toy.
We need to see how difficult it is.
- If he makes it, we'll [inaudible].
- Hold on.
Hold on.
OK.
I'm ready.
- [Executive producer:] Three, two, one.
- [Adam:] I don't know.
- [Ronnie and Adam:] Oh.
- That was pretty nice, though.
- It is hard.
- You can't even see it.